>>Nidia: Good afternoon everyone. Welcome
to another Authors@Google talk. I am happy
to introduce Les McKeown, author of 'Predictable
Success'. Les McKeown has launched and managed
over 40 businesses and is the co-founder of
an incubation company that helped hundreds
of entrepreneurs launch businesses, employing
thousands worldwide. This book hit the market
with a splash and is said to be an incredibly
useful blueprint for any leader who is looking
for sustainable growth. As per tradition,
we will have book signing and a 15 minute
Q & A at the end. We're just waiting for a
book thing to set up. So, with that said,
let's welcome Les.
[applause]
>>Les McKeown: Thank you very much, Nidia.
I appreciate it. And thank you for, all of
you for giving some time to be here. I appreciate
it. I want to thank the various folks who
helped me get here. Not the least, Jenny Blake
in her absence, Nidia Landria, and Alyssa.
I actually lived for a number of years from
1997 to about 2006 in Marin. So it's a little
bit frightening to realize that when I first
moved here, none of this existed. And now
I, well, it all exists. It's pretty bewilderin'.
I don't come from these parts as you might
gather from my accent. I'm from Texas. [laughter]
[laughs] I'm from Belfast in Ireland. Belfast
is the part of Ireland that you come from.
You go to Dublin, right? And you come from
Belfast and I've come from Belfast. But I
moved out in 1997 like I said and my accent
has decided not to relocate. So I'm just talkin'
for a little bit for you to get accustomed
to the cadences of my voice. The word that
you'll have most difficulty with is 'it'.
'It' is a number between seven and nine. [laughter]
But it's also part of a lot of words 'demonstrit',
'ingrati-it'. So if something isn't gelling,
it's because there's an 'it' in there somewhere
or other.
What I want to share with you today as Niddi
mentioned is essentially what's in my book
but I'm gonna prove that nobody needs to read
a book if you've got 45 minutes and the guy
who wrote it in the same room. [laughs] [laughter]
A lot of nodding going on. Because [clears
throat] I believe that I'm gonna be able to
communicate to you pretty comprehensively
more or less all that I've covered in there
because of the fact that it's pretty much
instantly intuitive. I doubt very much if
I'm gonna share with you anything this afternoon
that any of you are gonna think, 'Oh my goodness.
I never knew any of that.' What's gonna happen
is I'm gonna share with you a bunch of stuff
that you 'll recognize but almost certainly
you hadn't put a name to beforehand. And in
order to do that, I want to share with you
first of all a little bit of background about
myself. Not just because I like talking about
myself. But because I think it's important
for you to understand where what I am about
to show you came from. Because given that
I'm aware of the environment in which you
operate every day, what I'm about to say might
mean that all of you might leave the room
immediately at least mentally if not physically.
There isn't a single thing I'm about to show
you that is subject to objective proof. I'm
gonna show you what I have learned subjectively
over about 36 years or so doing what I do.
That doesn't mean that it doesn't have validity
obviously. But what it does mean is that you
need to know the context from which it came
from in order to ascribe whatever validity
you might put to it.
I qualified in the UK originally. This is
something I tried to keep a secret but unfortunately
the people that published the book actually
slapped it on the box. So I've had to start
to 'fess up to it again. I'm actually a CPA
by training or a chartered accountant which
is the somewhat posh name we give ourselves
back in the UK. A CPS. And I qualified as
a CPA not because I had any interest in CPA-ing
in terms of doing the legacy work of accounts
and tax and so forth. It was because I had
a freakishly developed interest in business
as a kid. I, I, I can't explain it. It's just
something weird that happened in my DNA at
some point. And I wanted to understand how
businesses worked. And somebody gave me a
really good piece of advice which was, 'If
you understand the numbers, then 90% of everything
else will flow from there.' Now I'm gonna
show you in a moment or two why that's not
true but it was a good starting point. By
the way, I hope you'll forgive me. I'm not
going to do any Power Point. Is that okay
with you? [audience chuckles] I'm not gonna
switch the lights off and flick at anything.
I'm, I'm beta testing a brand new technology.
I have downloaded everything I know about
the topic into these four small output devices
[audience chuckles] and I'm amazingly able
to access randomly whatever part of whatever
I want to share with you at any point and
it'll appear here as opposed to doing some
linear display up on the screen. And what
I'll show you in a moment or two began to
evolve as the result of the work I did when
I was in practice. What I started to do pretty
early on was to advise people on launching
businesses which was a ridiculous thing to
do because I didn't know anything about launching
businesses. But I happened to be working in
Northern Ireland at a time when there was
a, a very strong interest in launching indigenous
local businesses, largely because there was
such a high unemployment rate. There were
very few other options for other people. And
I was fascinated by this. So a number of people
were brave enough, dumb enough, something
enough to allow me to take my financial understanding
and try to help them build a business that
would succeed. Now of course you could pretty
quickly be able to work out what as an accountant,
I was brainwashed, sorry trained, to understand
was the most important thing in a business.
What do you reckon that might be?
>>male #1: Money.
>>Les McKeown: Money, cash, profits. The numbers,
the green, the dollar. All that sort of stuff.
Let's call it the finance. If the finance
was right, everything else would follow. And
so I worked very, very hard at trying to help
people understand that if we could get their
cash flow right, their balance sheet right,
their P and L account right, everything else
would follow. And that worked pretty well.
I got to be very good at what I do. I got
first place in the accounting exams that I
took. And to this day, just lookin' around
the room, there may not be enough of you who
are old enough to remember this. But you may
recall a couple of years ago, these printed
books came out. I think they were sort of
laser printed with dots and if you twisted
them a certain way in a strange light and
did weird things with your eyes, a dolphin
would leap out at you. Or a building would
appear. These 3-D representations. Well that's
sort of what happens when I look at a set
of financial statements. I can see the business.
It, it, it becomes a three dimensional thing.
And that comes out of all of that work I did
helping launch businesses. Now to fast forward
real quick by the time I was 35, I had on
my account or with other people launched 42
businesses.
Nothing spectacular; a specialist publishing
company, a tool and die manufacturing company,
probably an entire industry that barely exists
these days. Excuse me. I owned, I bought and
operated the Master License for Pizza Hut
in Ireland which was great fun trying to sell
flat Italian breads to Irish people. [audience
chuckles] We had no destination restaurants
then. There was no, there was no McDonald's.
There was no Wendy's. There was no Burger
King. There was nothing. We were the first
thing that was a destination branded restaurant.
And to this day you can still go to the first
Pizza Hut that I opened in a little town called
Carryduff.
And it's the only Pizza Hut in the world so
far as I am aware that is allowed to manufacture
and sell fries. The only way we could get
our compatriots to buy pizza was if they could
get potato in some form along with it. And
in fact, many people at the start when we
tried to spin the concept of choosing toppings,
wanted to know if chips as we call it was
one of the toppings. So I had a lot of fun
with that and, but even as a dumb Irish guy
which is my solid qualification, after you've
done something 40 something times with two
really painful failures, you begin to see
some patterns, okay? And one of the patterns
that I saw, in fact the most prominent pattern
that I saw was that a successful business
wasn't just about the numbers. It was about
the numbers, sure. It didn't, it did no harm
to get the business well financed, right?
But it was at least equally important that
you got the right people. In other words,
you could throw as much money as you wanted
at the wrong team and a bunch of idiots can
keep spending your money, right? And the first,
stripping out the reference, the totally unnecessary
reference to idiots, we could go back to the
first dot com boom and see that that happened
a lot. A lot of money was thrown at businesses
that spent it, went up in flames. There might
have been a perfectly good business idea underneath
that or not. You wouldn't know. On the other
hand, really good groups of people I discovered
could launch highly successful businesses
with very little money. We call it 'bootstrapping''
these days. But ideally you'd want them both
to be the same. You'd want good finance, good
team. That seemed to me to be the best combination.
So at that time when I was about 36, 37, the
UK government, which was then much more interventionist
in business, came along and asked me and one
other guy if we would start teaching other
people how to launch businesses. Essentially
what, if you know of them at all, organizations
like Techstar or Y Combinator are doing except
we didn't have a tech only focus. We were
focused on anything that would launch a reasonable
business. And the reason was simple. The UK
at that point was a branch economy of the
U.S. by and large and South Korea. We had
GM, Ford, Hyundai, Daewoo, LG, Lucky Gold
Star. All big employers in those days. But
if Ford took a cold that shut down a plant
in Liverpool, then 20,000 people would be
out of work. So what the UK government did
was ask myself and this one other guy who
was also a serial entrepreneur would we help
other people launch businesses.
Fast forward another 10 years with 120 people
in a consulting group worldwide. We've launched
about 3,000 businesses off the runway. We're
doing this in, in 13 offices around the world.
And we're just watching these businesses take
off like fighter planes off a ,whatever that
ship thing is,I'm trying to imagine with this
gesture with my hand what's the name of the
ship that has fighter planes on it.
>>male #2: Aircraft carrier.
>>Les McKeown: Aircraft carrier. That's it.
Okay.
Tortured metaphors -- not good. So [clears
throat] here's the weird thing. About two
to three years into this phase, this incubation
phase where we're helping people launch businesses,
what do you think might start to happen to
some of those businesses?
>>Audience Member: [inaudible]
>>Les McKeown: Some of them started to tank.
Correct. And this was not a pleasant experience
for us and certainly it wasn't a pleasant
experience for them. In fact, our remuneration,
the way we got paid, was largely focused on
job creation numbers. That's the reason why
the government agencies were paying us to
help start these private businesses. And every
time one of them closed, that was a net job
loss and they were trying to do a thing that
I had to struggle very hard to get my head
around. They were trying to do a thing called
'taking money back' which is not an idea that
an Irish person really carries around much
in their head. Every pine is a prisoner back
there. But we started to get call backs on
what we were being paid. It was also, both
intellectually and professionally incredibly
disheartening. Because we were working on
this twin track of having well financed businesses
with really good teams. We were doing a lot
of hard work to put good quality teams together.
[clears throat] And so I got personally obsessed
with trying to understand why these businesses,
two to three years down the line, despite
fitting our template, were still failing.
And this was setting aside those businesses
that had a perfectly understandable reason
to fail ;like the market got away from them
or technology changed immediately or they
had an economic headwind or whatever. These
were good businesses run by good business
people, well financed and yet still a high
percentage of them,well, it wasn't a high
percentage but it was a high enough percentage
were starting to fail to bother me. It was
at that point that I moved over to the US.
I sold my share in the, in the business. I
wanted to focus on nothing but trying to understand
why second stage growth was such a problem
for these businesses. And we'd been doing
work, we had offices here in San Francisco
and in Toronto and in Boston. I came over
here, took that work over, got a much bigger
area to play with and began to look at solely
trying to understand why this was happening.
And pretty much,not right away, but six to
nine months at trying to work at this, it
became obvious to me intuitively that there
could only be one other variable. If we had
the money right and we had good teams, the
only thing that could have changed was the
structure, the environment within which those
teams were operating, and within which the
funding was operating too. That something
must be shifting within the structure of the
business. It also seemed to me likely that
although I was looking at this because I'd
bumped my nose against this one specific point
of change, call it 'second stage growth',
whatever you want. It seemed to me highly
likely there were other flex points or pivot
points, call it what you want. And I devoted
really all of the time from '97 through to
about 2003 trying to get a handle on what
they were. I had this huge database of all
the businesses that I'd worked with before
and helped launch and I had a lot of people
out here who helped me, at their time and
expense and energy, work at this. And also
a lot of good people who had done a lot of
good research and work on it beforehand. And
anyway, here's what I discovered over time.
Now what I'm gonna show you, I'm gonna talk
about it and explain it in the context of
business and in the context of an organization
overall. But what I discovered going through
is what I'm about to show you applies to any
group of two or more people who are trying
to achieve common goals. I have shared this
with marriage guidance counselors, two or
more people trying to achieve common goals.
I've shared it with non-profits, with NGOs,
with divisions, departments, groups, teams,
soccer leagues, mom and kids, yoga groups,
and Fortune 100 businesses, and mom and pop
businesses. Any group of two or more people
trying to achieve common goals goes through
the same seven stages and let me share them
with you.
[pause]
[draws on board] Let me give this a slightly
nicer rounded thing. What happens with all
businesses is that they go through seven stages,
four of which indicated by these wiggly lines,
are clearly points of difficulty. And three
of which indicated by these rather straighter
lines are theoretically smooth, more smooth
running. In fact, one of the last difficult
areas is a trap, we'll see that, why that
is in just a moment or two. But essentially
what happens is that every business, every
organization, every group that's trying to
get started goes through initially a stage
that I call 'early struggle'. Pretty self
evident that any organization would go through
a stage of early struggle. In business terms,
what do you think the struggle is about? What's
the struggle for? Yeah.
>>male #2: [inaudible]
>>Les McKeown: And not just any old customers.
Any particular types of customers do you think?
>>male #2: [inaudible]
>>Les McKeown: What's that?
>>Les McKeown: Might be.
>>male #3: [inaudible]
>>Les McKeown: What's that? Sustainable. Right.
No longer a point of getting customers that
are one off and dead. Like that's the, your
uncle who started to sell life insurance story
because he was able to sell it to four people
in his family but then couldn't sell squat
to anybody else so he didn't have sustainable
customers. What else would you really like
these customers to be?
>>Audience Member: [inaudible]
>>Les McKeown: That they pay and pay what?
>>Les McKeown: More than you charged. You
want them to be profitable. See if we can
get a sustainable customer base almost for
anything if we're prepared to give up profitability.
And it's actually not that hard to get a profitable
customer base if you don't need sustainability.
Really what this early struggle is all about,
it's a, it's a race over time to do this.
[draws] Two sources of income. First one is
our external source: funding, bankers, venture
capitol, selling everything you own, selling
everything your spouse owns, paying off the
divorce, getting Aunt Jenny's 401K. And you
want to replace that from your profitable,
sustainable income from your profitable, sustainable
market. [pause] [draws on board] So what this
early struggle about, is all about, is finding
a profitable, sustainable market. That make
sense? Of course, what's the, what's the fuel
in the tank at this point? What is it that
this business needs every day to be able to
keep going along the time axis here? What
does this business need? What's its fuel?
>>Audience Member: [inaudible]
>>Les McKeown: It's cash. All right. This
is all about do we have enough cash to get
through tomorrow and next week and the week
after until we find this profitable, sustainable
market? Now just as a little aside, what do
you think over-funding might do to this race
to find our profitable, sustainable market?
You get a funky little startup, gets a whole
bunch. Somebody gets really excited about
it and throws a few million at it and it only
needs 40,000. What do you think it might do
to the absolute need to find that market?
Will it heighten it or dull it?
>>male #4: Dull it.
>>Les McKeown: Sure. We didn't get any closer
to finding a profitable sustainable market
today but we got new Aeron chairs. Yay. We
built a new conference room. Yay. One of the
things that happens here is that most organizations,
as a matter of interest by the way, do you
want to take a stab at the percentage businesses
that get through early struggle? What do you
reckon? It's about one in five, about 20%.
The IRS and other record keepers will tell
you that about two-thirds of all businesses
fail in the first three to five years. But
from my ex-CPA days, what I can tell you is
that it's a huge number of businesses never
even file with the IRS. They never put anything
on paper. They, they come up and disappear
before that even happens. So there's a, a,
really high, forgive me for using this phrase
but it's the way it is, there's a high infant
death syndrome here. And 80% of all businesses
fail. And those that succeed do so largely
because they keep their eye on the prize,
yes sir.
>>male #5: Do you mind if I ask you a question?
>>Les McKeown: Not at all.
>>male #5: So when you say they fail, is that
'cause they ran out of cash or they couldn't
[inaudible]? [inaudible] what determined their
failure.
>>Les McKeown: They just don't get to this
point here. They never get the crossover and
at some point, the source of external funding
just runs out. Yeah. And so we have about
twenty percent of the businesses that get
through here and the ones that do are the
ones who keep their eye on that prize. I do
a dumb thing with the businesses that I work
with where I ask them to actually get a klaxon
or a horn or a bell or something and ring
it every time something happened that gets
them closer to knowing what their profitable,
sustainable market is and it's dumb but it
works. Keeps their eyes focused on that. Now
for those businesses that get through this
early struggle stage, what I discovered is
they hit this first stage of high growth.
I've given this a really technical term if
you bear with me. I call this 'fun' 'cause
that's what it is. The fun stage. Why do you
think it might be fun to be working for a
business that's made it through early struggle
and has survived? It's found its profitable,
sustainable market. Why do you think that
might be fun?
>>male #6: Because the bad times are over.
>>Les McKeown: Yeah. 'Cause it's not early
struggle. Right? This is like not banging
your head on the wall any more. Oh we stopped
doing that. That's nice. It's great fun because
it's not like this. At this point here, you've
got this thing in the back of your neck every
day. Can I meet the payroll at the end of
the month? Can I meet our supplier expenses?
Are they going to pay us in time to pay that?
Can I juggle this with that? And then some
day somebody walks in and says, 'Hey. You
know what? We can meet payroll tomorrow.'
I say, 'No. You've made a mistake. Go check.
There's something wrong with the bank figure.
That can't be right.' 'No. We can meet payroll.'
And then the next month, you meet payroll
again. You're bewildered. Three, four months
later, you can actually start to take something
for yourself. Before you know it, hey we've
got this profitable sustainable market. We've
made it. We get through early struggle to
where the fun is. To hugely generalize, this
is sort of three to five years but this is
a massive generalization. Now what happens
in finance is that the business grows really
fast. Can you think of any obvious reasons
why this small business might be able to post
double digit growth for a number of years?
>>male #7: Starting from nothing?
>>Les McKeown: Starting from 0.001% of the
market share All we've done is discover the
sustainable market. Now we're mining it and
so we can get double digit, sometimes triple
digit growth for a period of time. And also
everybody's so enthusiastic. Everybody's so
pumped up. Everybody's so excited. Everybody's
so full of belief that you work for fun and
you're walkin' down one side of the street
and somebody's who knows you is dumb enough
to wave at you from the other side of the
street. You'll walk over and they'll end up
buyin' whatever you're selling 'cause you're
enthusiastic and excited and the team is really
focused and we feel like there's a lot we
can do and we don' t have a lot of market
share to start with. So we can grow really
fast. And this is when the myths, the legends
of the business gets built. This is when we're
snatching victory out of the jaws of defeat
on like a weekly basis. This is where a customer
asks for 'X' and we deliver 'two X'. Now we
might deliver it two minutes before it was
due but we get it done. The customer orders
500 widgets in blue on Friday for delivery
Monday. We get an e-mail over the weekend
saying, 'We're sorry. We made a mistake. We
want it in pink.' What do we do? Everybody
gets on their hands and knees and repaints
these widgets pink. And we get them out there
just about on time. But we're excited. We
have another story to tell and we go have
a beer bust. It's fun. It's, make sense? Familiar
with that stage? Now at this point, what's
happening is we've moved away from this emphasis
on cash for the [clears throat],excuse me,for
the business and fun. What it's all about
for most businesses is just sell, sell, sell.
It's actually about whatever the core thing
is the business does. So this is a, if this
is a new hospital, it's about heal, heal,
heal. [pause] [writes on board] It might be
about code, code, code. Whatever the thing
that defines us, whatever it is that we do
for most commercial organizations is sell
it, whatever the thing it is, we do it and
boy, do we do it. And we do it highly, in
a highly flexible mode. We do it in a way
that's very responsive. It's cool and it's
fun.
But then what happens is the organization
hits a stage that's inherent and [pause] natural,
I'm gonna redraw this the way it should be.
[pause] And a natural result of fun. The business
is growing fast. And what does that mean is
likely to be happening to the business as
it grows? Is it getting simpler or less simple?
What do you reckon?
>>male #8: Less simple.
>>Les McKeown: I'm lobbing some softballs
for the folks who had pizza. The business
is getting more complex every step up here,
right? And what happens is that, sure as shooting,
any business that's in fun and grows for awhile
will ultimately hit a stage that I call 'whitewater'.
A whitewater is a point when the growing complexity
of the business begins to cause us to cause
errors. We begin to drop the ball. We buy
the wrong product for this customer. We deliver
this to the wrong place. We don't get the
repainting done from pink to blue. We completely
screw up the installation of something. Now
of course what happens in the first instance
is the founder owner group, because it's typically
still the founder owner here, just put it
down to chance. Nidia wasn't in the warehouse
that day. She's the one that does all our
purchasing. She knows precisely how we do
all of this thing. When she comes back, it's
fine. But six months later when we discover
that not only is it not just down to Nidia,
that we actually have a systemic problem.
That the business doesn't have the systems
and processes necessary to deliver consistent
quality in the face of complexity. What's
happening here is we not only do but are identified
by our ability to deliver consistent quality
in the face of simplicity. But here we're
having to learn what it truly means to scale
the business and truly scaling a business
means delivering consistent quality in the
face of complexity. Does that make sense?
It means we need something very, very simple,
very straightforward which are systems and
processes. We gotta put some systems and processes
in place. And the good news that I get to
give to people in my world is very often I
go speak to founders/owners who think their
business is dying here. They think this is
what's happening 'cause this just seems natural.
This is how a business should be. And when
this whitewater starts to happen, they actually
think they're down here. But what I am able
to help them with is that if we can put the
right systems and processes in place, we can
actually break through to the stage that I
call 'predictable success' which is like fun
except you're in control. You can scale the
business indefinitely. You have the systems
and processes to grow the business to whatever
size you want it to be. Now of course it should,the
story should stop there and we should all
get our business there and keep it there.
But the reality is that what happens and I'm
gonna deal with this in a second but really
quick,but having done a thing that was a good
thing, we put some systems and processes in
and it got us through whitewater, what do
you think typically we then do if we just
did a good thing?
>>Audience Member: [inaudible]
>>Les McKeown: More of it or less of it? We
do more of it. And what happens with most
organizations is we get to the point where
we over-systematize. We put too many systems
and processes in place and the business begins
to get arthritic and it tilts forward into
the first of the decline stages which I call
'treadmill'. And a business in treadmill is
simply that. It is a business where form has
begun to become more important than function.
Where face time is more important than delivering.
Where filling in checklists is more important
than the point that the checklist was there
to achieve. Where we just start to go through
the motions. We're not as committed to shipping,
to delivering, to precision. We've become
too fixated with efficiency, with the way
in which things are done. And that's a natural
point. Most organizations swing between here.
That's perfectly fine and high performing
management teams keep that swing here. Less
well performing management teams allow it
to go like this. But treadmill is pretty natural.
What's not natural, 'cause what can happen
here in treadmill is that you can recover,
you can recognize what's happened and pull
off on the systems and processes and go back.
If you don't do that, however, the business
falls into what I call 'the big rut'. And
what happens with the big rut, which though
I've shown like this, actually looks more
like this, because we've technically grown
a lot of legacy income, we typically have
a monopolistic or near monopolistic position
by this stage, We're typically a relatively
big organization so we can hang on in the
big rut for a long time. The difference between
the big rut and treadmill is that in the big
rut, we've lost the power to self-diagnose.
In treadmill, we know we've over systematized
and we want to fix it. In the big rut, we
like it that way. Ever been to the DMV? We
like it that way. And you, the customer, are
getting in our way. I have an educational
establishment as a client which has been in
the big rut for about 312 years. [audience
laughs] Okay? The difference between treadmill
which is a natural orange blinking light and
the big rut which essentially means your business
will die eventually is that in treadmill you
can self-diagnose and in big rut, you can't.
And once you're in the big rut, it's only
a question of time before the business hits
what I call 'death rattle'. [pause] And death
rattle, that's it. Lights are out. The business
will go. There's no recovery from it. Sure
somebody might come in and buy it all out
of receivership, take the name, take the brand
and so forth but essentially, it's not gonna
go any further.
Now what I'd like to finish off with before
taking some questions, and I'm sorry. I appreciate
that I'm fire-hosing it here a little bit,
but I think it's worthwhile trying to show
you the full model. What I'd like to share
with you in closing are the underlying key
dynamics that cause this to happen. Remember
we talked about the financial structure, the
people, and the underlying organizational
structure. What's essentially happening here
is this. The management style of the business,
the way in which it is being managed, is essentially
the key driver of this. Let's go right back
to the outset here in early struggle. What
do you call the sort of idiot,sorry,person,who
sits at the kitchen table at three am with
a perfectly good job and says, 'I can't stand
this. I'm gonna start up a new business.'
What sort of words do we use to describe that
type of person?
>>male #9: Entrepreneurial.
>>Les McKeown. Entrepreneurial. What else?
What else have they got, do you think?
>>male #10: [inaudible]
>>Les McKeown: What's that?
>>male #10: Passion
>>Les McKeown: They've got a lot of passion.
Yeah. Got a lot of passion. You need that
passion and enthusiasm to get through early
struggle. Can you see if you don't have that
with, with this knockout writ, you get knocked
down. You don't have that passion and enthusiasm,
that vision, you're never gonna see it through.
The visionary,let's put a 'V' up here, the
visionary is the person,it's the style that
gets the business up and going through early
struggle. Do you think if you were a funder,if
somebody came to you who was solely a visionary
and nothing else, would you give them the
money? If all they had was a vision and nothing
else, what's missing?
>>Audience Member: [inaudible]
>>Les McKeown: Somebody's gotta do it, right?
Somebody's gotta do this stuff. So typically
what happens here is that the visionary gets
the business idea, gets the notion, the concept
but it's a 'V' and an 'O',an operator. The
person that makes the railroads run on time.
It's a 'V' and an 'O'. It's a classic mom
and pop but it's also any start up model.
A 'V' and an 'O' will get the business up
and going. Now it's that 'V' and 'O' that
push the business through fun. The vision
gets the ideas. The visionary gets the ideas.
The operator's out there making it happen.
They're very symbiotic. Can you see they work
off each other? Visionary's very long term
focused. Operator's short term focused. Visionary's
thinking things up. The operator is out there
getting it done. Operator is releasing endorphins
by gettin' stuff done. What use would an operator
be without a visionary? If somebody came to
you who was just an operator, really good
at getting things done, but had no vision,
would you fund them? This is the perfect funding
team. Now sometimes it's two people. Sometimes
it's one person who's slightly schizophrenic.
Sometimes it's twelve people and they share
the various roles. Jeff Bezos, Amazon, big
'V', tells a great story about himself with
his, I think the guy went on to become a Chief
Financial Officer for awhile but was essentially
in my terms, his 'O'. And Jeff Bezos tells
the story about on their knees in the early
days in his garage, literally packing books,
which is fascinating when you see those big
pictures of the Amazon world. Bezos, the 'V'
says to his 'O', 'What do you think about
this?' And the 'O' says, 'To be honest, we
can't keep going like this.' And Jeff says,
'No. You're right. We need knee pads.'
[audience laughter]
'No. Jeff. We need people, tables, chairs,
systems, processes. ' So the 'V' and the 'O'
take the business up here but as it becomes
more and more complex, you'd think the 'V'
and the 'O' mindset, this highly effective,
get it done, very flexible, turn on a dime,
couple are good at putting systems and processes
in place? Nah. They just wanna do it. The
need the endorphin rush each time.. Let's
get this thing done. And what happens classically
in whitewater is that a third management style
comes on board and it gets emphasized or somebody
gets hired in or it gets accentuated and that's
the processor management style. The 'V' and
the 'O' realize intellectually that we need
to start bringing some systems and processes
to bear. We really can't get through here
unless and until we've got some systems and
processes in place but we don't want to do
it so we'll bring other people in and we'll
ask them and we'll heighten them, and we'll
give them a role and tell them to do it. Sounds
perfect, right? The problem is this is a highly
unstable triad. See, the 'O' by this stage
here up in fun, laid fun, when all this is
starting to happen, what do you think the
'O' is spending all of his, who's fixing all
of these mistakes that are beginning to happen?
Is it the 'V' or the 'O'?
>>Audience Member: [inaudible]
>>Les McKeown: It's the 'O'. Of course it
is. The 'V' is having too many more bright
ideas. So the 'O' has become a firefighter.
The 'O' is firefighting. The problem is, here's
the arsonist. A lot of the firefighting is
happening because 'Vs' like to walk around
with a book of matches. Whoosh. Let's open
an office in Mongolia. Whoosh.
[audience laughs]
Let's invent time travel. Whoosh. [audience
laughter] And the 'O' is the one that's having
to pull all of this together and fix stuff.
So originally the 'O' thinks when systems
and processes get elevated, when a 'P' is
brought in, the 'O' thinks, 'Oh thank goodness.
This is gonna calm everything down.' But who
does the V think the systems and processes
are for? Let me ask it another way. Who do
they not think it's for? Everybody but themselves.
Because why do people start businesses? Because
they want autonomy above all else. That's
the number one reason people start businesses.
It's why the visionaries start businesses.
They want autonomy. And of course everything
'P' does is like this to the 'V'. The 'V'
and the 'P' in the worse situation can be
like oil and water. We don't have time to
go into it but it's a highly unstable arrangement.
So what I've seen, and I'll close with this
in order to take your questions,what I've
seen in organizations happen a lot is that
often this move into whitewater happens, there's
an intellectual ascent on behalf of the 'V'
and the 'O' team that really brought the business
to here. Remember highly effective, highly
flexible, highly fluid, love to do new things.
They've got a lot of sweat equity together.
They've known each other for a long time.
The 'P' element comes into the business and
then everything starts to slow down because
we're starting to put systems and processes
in place. And often what happens is ultimately
the 'V' and the 'O' feel that things have
even actually got worse. This isn't fixing
the thing. We want to go back to the way it
was. Let's go back to, we start to talk about
'back in the day'. We might even start to
talk about 'them' and 'us'. I am of 'V'. I
am of 'P'. And what happens is that well,
let me ask you. If you think there's a fight
between these three, who gets ostracized first?
'P'. No sweat equity. No history. And looks
like they've caused the problem to get worse
And what I've seen many, many times is that
organizations actually go in and out of fun
and whitewater, three, four, five times. They
try this. The 'P' doesn't work out. They go
back down to fun. Grow again back into whitewater
and back and forward. And what I've seen happen
in those organizations that get to predictable
success is that although they wouldn't use
this terminology, these three managements
styles which are highly visceral management
styles get added to, get complimented by a
learned management style. It's a style I call
a 'synergist'. It's not a great word but it's
the best one I can think of. And essentially
what a synergist management style is is a
realization that we have to have systems and
processes for the long term but they've gotta
work with the people in our organization and
with our culture. It's the synergist mindset
that translates for these people that smooths
the way, that enables them to talk to each
other. And it's that synergist mindset that
appear when we get all four of these working
together that the organization can stay in
predictable success. And it's when one of
those begins to feel under pressure and leaves,
or gets pushed down that the organization
comes unbalanced and will either fall backwards
into whitewater or forward into treadmill.
I promise I'd stop at the 45 minute level
and take some questions. And I'm gonna do
that. But I hope that's been helpful to you
and that it's been useful. Thanks. Questions?
>>Male Audience Member #11: [speaking with
an Irish accent] I have a couple of questions.
May I say, one of the other action items,
>>Les McKeown: I'm sorry. I don't understand
a word you're saying. Could you say that again?
[audience laughter]
>>male #11: A couple of items,there's currently
in Northern Ireland, you might be familiar
with the health and social care monitoring
system . Medicine is an areas where there's
a lot of process, unnecessarily so, a lot
of legal liability, et cetera. So you have
service organizations moving into that market
supplying services to government and all the
other [inaudible] players in the market. How
does this vary by that kind of area because
a lot of the process that's been put in place
is actually required and is very, very strict
and it's using a lot of services people that
wouldn't necessarily be able to stand up and
change the business.
>>Les McKeown: Yeah. A lot of health and education
is right here. It's either in the big rut
or it's teetering towards it. Certainly in
treadmill. And irrespective of the industry,
there are cultural problems that happen. Of
course what then happens is people come up
with really bright ideas to change the face
of a wide industry. Btu what they're doing
is they're starting here and they're trying
to contract with an organization there. Now
so long as the organization there keeps throwing
lots of money over here, that'll smooth the
thing out. But ultimately what happens is
this doesn't take because they don't speak
the same vocabulary. The relationship breaks,
the money flow stops, and these people get
[makes squeezing gesture]. Happens all the
time. Working within, across a span that wide
is really tough. It's not, it's not, you can
see organizations working from here to here,
but from here to here is really, really hard.
There's a lot of, perfectly, there's a whole
industry of I wouldn't say bottom feeding
firms but that's essentially what they do.
Organizations are quite happy to stay small
and be flexible and just picking up little
contracts and make a lot of money. But not
a lot of medium or long term satisfaction
in that because you're not really changing
anything. Any other questions, folks? [pause]
Any comments or observations?
>>Audience Member: [inaudible]
>>Les McKeown: That's a really good question.
What I see happen a lot is that organizations
get up to here. When they start to hit treadmill
and become over processed, it's the 'V' who's
the first one to dislike that. And what they'll
often do is either they'll say, 'Screw it.
This isn't what I signed up for.' And they'll
leave and go back to do something else. Or
they'll say, 'Screw it. I don't like the way
this organization is.' And they'll just take
the business right back to here. Try to return
to fun. One of the things that I thinks happened
real well in Apple and I don't, I can't prove
this but I think we'll get the proof of it
in the next couple of years, is that the way
to really lock in an organization to predictable
success is by institutionalizing the 'V' function
and depersonalizing it, taking it away from
being the sole, being solely personified by
one or more people. Now I think Steve Jobs'
done a very good job of in PR terms, putting
himself out there as the highly obviously,
the big 'V' of Apple but I think what we'll
discover is that in there, there are a lot
of V's right through the org chart. And that's
really what locks a business in predictable
success for a very long time is when the 'V'
role is depersonified. Sure you can continue
to have some 'V' figureheads. But if those
people have really worked hard at pushing
it down through the organization. So you say
'this group', 'that group', 'this product
area', 'this geographical area' have all got
their own 'V', then that really helps lock
predictable success in.
>>male #12: You mentioned Y-Combinator and
a bunch of [inaudible] and I was wondering
what you think that says about [inaudible]
and what works and what doesn't in that [inaudible]?
>>Les McKeown: I think first of all that YComm
and Techstars are all doing a great, great
job. I think anything that helps reduce this
figure is, is super. What I see happen a lot,
let's set aside whether it's YComm or Techstar
or whatever, but just in tech funding in general,
is that if you blow up the early struggle
thing, you take this bit, just this bit here,
in fact what happens is that a whole life
cycle happens inside that early struggle,
that there are two separate things going on.
One is the early stage funding, cash out,
get to this point here, struggle, issue and
then there's the meta level of what will be
this business look like 15 years, 20 years,
30 years from now? And so what I see happen
is that if you were to blow up that early
struggle stage, the business actually goes
through its own mini-life cycle which is all
about getting the initial funding right, the
equity right, getting the second stage, getting
my share out and then eventually we get to
the point where, oh we've just got a normal
business. Let's get going. One of the things
that can happen which is problematic is that
sometimes external VC money tries to make
a little startup be this right from Day One.
So they put a Board together. They throw a
bunch of money at it. They bring the 'P' in
very early on to manage the money. And the
business can't take the weight of it and it's
the same reason internal fund groups often
don't work is that sometimes a large organization
will try a little start up but will essentially
want it to start operating in predictable
success immediately and it's put all these
resources behind it. The business has got
to grow through these natural stages. This
choreography of  'V', 'V O', 'V O P', 'V
O P S' -- you can't skip that stuff and just
germinate this perfect little business much
as everybody would like to.
>>male #13: [inaudible] What do you think
are the most critical [inaudible] in that
small paradigm? What do you think are the
most critical pitfalls that small companies
[audience member sneezes] [inaudible] trying
to [inaudible].
>>Les McKeown: Not, not trying to find a long
term profitable sustainable market. Trying
to jigger the numbers to make it look like
something we can hang a valuation on is not
finding a long term sustainable, profitable
market. Literally finding a, it's fun these
days and popular to talk about pivots and
changing and shifting. All that is if you
strip it down is finding a long term sustainable,
profitable market. Anything you do and a lot
of people I talk to are just using vocabulary
to mystify something which should be very,
very simple which is what's your product or
service and who's your long term sustainable
market. And if you can't answer that, you've
gotta go out and answer that and no amount
of , no prospectus that will get you another
round of funding is going to change the underlying
dynamic. It may give you more time but you
still gotta find your long term, sustainable,
profitable market.
>>male #14: [inaudible] What are some of the
tactics that seem to be A) very successful
and B) be a waste of time to try to get back
into the whitewater [inaudible]?
>>Les McKeown: Yeah and in treadmill there
are four, four key touch points. First is
you gotta look really hard at your hiring
because in treadmill, hiring becomes an amplifier.
Essentially what's happening in treadmill
is that the 'P' mindset is running first and
foremost. And so we start to hire people that
got a 'P' preponderance who will confirm,
conform with systems and processes. We hire
people who are gonna deliver compliance as
opposed to delivering creativity. So you gotta
look at your hiring and make sure. 'Cause
hiring is really the water coming into the
lake. Right? It's the only thing that's gonna
refresh what's there. Secondly the way in
which you conduct performance assessment.
Typically in treadmill, performance assessments
begin to become risk and consequence focused.
'What did you not do?' 'What did you fail
on?' And 'what were the consequences of that?'
as opposed to being focused on 'What did you
do really well? What did you succeed at? And
how can we bottle that in the organization?
How can we push that out to wider parts of
the business?' And the two other things are
the training function. Classically in treadmill,
training has again begun to move towards a
compliance base. It's begun to become a way
in which you insure that all the boxes are
ticked and we're covered. Our people have
got, been touched at all these points and
they know what they should know. And to turn
the training function into something that
encourages creativity. All the good stuff
that you're doin'. That's three. And mentoring
and coaching. One of the key things in treadmill
is you've gotta give people an opportunity
to do things wrong. It's like a golfer whose
swing's gone bad. There's no point trying
to get him to fix it on the back nine on Sunday.
You gotta get him off to the range and let
him hit a hundred balls and keep trying stuff
until they get the groove back. And mentoring
and coaching that takes people off line and
lets them make mistakes is very, very important.
[pause]
>>male #15: Thank you for your talk. I wonder
[clears throat] in terms of a stage [inaudible].
>>Les McKeown: Which stage were you askin'
me about?
>>male #15: [inaudible]
>>Les McKeown: Tech companies tend to shorten
the left side here and lengthen the right
side. If they get to the right side. And it's
all about money. They get through here faster
because they can often get access to more
funding at this size. I hear they can often
build up more of a war chest than a non-tech
company and so they can slide quietly here
for a lot longer. And I'm not gonna do it
with a camera here but it wouldn't take too
hard, too long for us to think of a couple
of companies that started out as tech companies
that got a massive war chest. And they may
well be certainly in treadmill if not working
very hard to not have fallen into the big
rut. So accelerated down here and lengthened
up on this side largely because of revenues,
profitabilities higher than in a manufacturing
company typically. You can put an awful lot
of your cash away compared to a manufacturing
company typically.
>>male #16: What about disruptive technologies
[inaudible]. Cash cows [inaudible] strip that
profit away.
>>Les McKeown: It may not be exactly the answer
to the question that you want but it sounds
so good in my head. So I'll give it to you
anyway. I talk in the book about people I
call 'early struggle obsessives'. And early
struggle obsessives often in the tech side
are people who actually don't have really
any interest even in this stage, they don't
wanna get into anything that's sort of like
a business but what they love to do is find
a destructive technology and find a way to
monetize it. And then once they've done that,
they wanna go back and do it again. And soon
I've a lot of friends in Boston who are working
with three, four, five tech start ups because
it's finding the destructive technology where
they get their buzz. And once they've done
it, the idea of us getting revenue from a
customer base, ugh. Freaky. Right? Now what
can sometimes happen is you get that person
who is more interested in the disruptive technology.
They do it themselves on to somebody who is
more interested in the business and that can
either be a great success or it can be horrible
to watch because the early struggle obsessive
is the one that's fixated about the disruptive
technology can often just get self damaging.
They can begin, in business terms, cut themselves.
They don't want success so they'll keep trying
to pull the business down. That can get really
messy, really freaky. Time for one more? [pause]
We're done. Thank you very much indeed.
[applause]